[Music]
welcome to our Independence Day special
we have a very fun show here on the five
we're answering all of your fan mail
questions from social media on this
fourth of July so let's not waste any
more time and get right to it our very
first question it comes from Ronald buck
Bowers and it says if you could go back
to the first Independence Day which
founding father would you hang out with
Kimberly um well let's see I don't know
I guess one of my favorites always is
John Adams why well because I think he
was just historically very significant I
think that you know people more recently
have come to understand his value his
influence and how important he was in
American political history to some of
his ideals and and also his wife I think
they're quite a powerful pair the wife
of John Adams yeah that's true and also
I think they're too Adams presidents
right yes yeah that's pretty cool yes
Franklin because I'm a Philly guy and he
was a big influence down in Philadelphia
was laid to rest there also a real
renaissance man like myself a musician
the prolific writers discovered
electricity so we have a lot in common
on that front and the Poor Richard's
very inspiring quotes about work and
life and I enjoy that I'd like to hang
with Ben that's cool and I bet you share
humility thanks Dana where would you be
hanging out I like George Washington
I've always admired in plastic Menino
hear about Rules of Civility
remember all of those rules that you
have to follow choice yeah I'm gonna ask
him about that cherry tree you know
what's interesting about your answers I
don't think he was married right not for
the longest time Martha comes along but
for the longest time I don't know when
he got married but they were married are
you saying she wants to hang out with
very strange the father of our country
because he wasn't preoccupied with a lot
of families oh yeah he was busy guy on
his mind in our founding father at this
very table Greg I'd have to say Bob Lutz
he's the unknown founding father nobody
talks about Bob but he was there every
step of the way
Bob Lutz you don't know Pablo I don't I
rest my case I have to say I find this
whole question sexist are we done with
the whole idea of founding fathers what
about founding mothers founding founders
founding founders and why are we
recognizing gender anyway with our
founding fathers
so heteronormative back to the purple
penguin thing yes hmm well I think I'd
hang out with you guys would Ben and you
okay that'd be because I mean Ben's in
the newspaper business you know yes
right so I would like that he was a
partier he had two beds in his in his
bedroom because we get tired when the
bed was warm and so we get up and moved
to the other bed because it was cool
that sounds like you yes the temperature
controls yeah Wow okay let's do another
question it says here this one comes
from Patricia Hazleton how do you like
to celebrate the fourth of July yes
Jesse beer barbecue and fireworks
fireworks Dana
well I'm gonna say dogs no I don't know
I just I like hanging out being with
everybody I love to I like to go to the
parade wherever I am I like a small town
parade big town parade but usually small
town parade is really good and lately
because Peter has the hardly with a
sidecar and then Jasper can get in it
and that all the kids love that so I
like the morning of the fourth of July
even better than fireworks Wow well I
don't like fireworks
I'm like a dog they scare me and I don't
like parades because I'm short I can't
see over people but I'm gonna be honest
with everybody I know I hope people will
talk I wanna be honest I'm actually not
here I'm not here I'm celebrating the
fourth of July the way I would like to
right now I'm sitting on an island
I'm not gonna tell you what Island but
I'm sitting on an island right now
they're gonna show okay well I'm like
Dean I love a good parade I also really
enjoyed Deena's fourth of July posts and
pictures with pretty good lately they've
been very strong so I love it really
just like celebrating our nation our
independence our Liberty our freedom and
I think it's great when people come
together and go in a parade and I'm into
that the whole deal to commemorate it
and you know take a moment cuz we all
have such busy lives to never forget you
know the sacrifices that people made so
that we can sit here today and have this
show and speak our minds and it's
fantastic it's amazing most wonderful
country in the world so my favorite is
to find a high spot in Washington DC to
watch the fireworks but the one I
remember most is being in Boston and
watching the Boston Pops play as the
fireworks were going off over Boston I
thought that was spectacular and who's
that Arthur I forget the name of the
famous conductor
anyway it was Hiedler Arthur field thank
you very much it was I was unbelievable
yeah and the other thing I liked about
the fourth of July is just it's an
opportunity to do fireworks mm-hmm
so fireworks when I was the kid mostly
illegal but everybody would bring it on
these trash cans and these big boom boom
boom I love that stuff best place to see
fireworks right now my hot tub West they
do fireworks at in the range yeah well
some years there's because it's so
drowsy out there that they don't like to
have fireworks in case their that starts
a wildfire so sometimes we would just
get those little snakes and sparklers
that was usually the extent that's
that's really laying the weakest type of
firework you got to get the roman
candles yeah those are the way to go or
the m-80s I'm against roman candles
cultural appropriation all right here's
the third question from Cindy Carol
Allen Carly what traditions did you have
for the fourth of July when you were
children so let's go back this way
Kimberly yes you're on woman
brother and I used to really love to do
the fireworks and so it was a big it was
really fun to be able to go and shop for
that one that's we do and so I love that
so we would do that and go pick out the
fireworks it was like a family tradition
to go and get him ahead of time and we
do a whole thing on the block to you
know do the fireworks to invite
everybody to come and then my dad had us
sweep up the streets after to clean up
my works and then my brother would
stockpile them and then the fire
department came and we got in trouble
that's a rarity for you as a kid to get
well it was mostly due to my brother I
was dragged in you got a waiver there I
did the same thing fireworks were
illegal in Philadelphia so we'd have to
go down to Chinatown or way across state
lines somewhere else and then bring them
across and then light them and I'd do it
with my dad and I still have all my
fingers so safety first safety first I'm
glad to hear that I think there's a New
York Giants football player who could
have used that less we do a family
baseball game or fighting a softball
game and picnic but that was always a
big deal what position would you play I
don't really remember it was more like
that they were kind of serious about it
the adults they probably stick you out
and right you used to do something
called fireworks you guys heard about
that yeah we go get some fire we're not
scared you know you know what they scare
you know it was always the best part was
not it was going shopping because you'd
always have to go to these stands that
were wrote by your school and you'd
either have to buy like you wanted the
big box and the big box had all the
stuff in it but you weren't sure if you
had all the right stuff so then you
fight and then all of a sudden it just
got banned
do they have fireworks in California
there's a - patriotic no no no yes it's
uh it's we used to have them and then
they took them away like they've taken
it global warming probably yeah well I
got to tell you for me when I was the
kid I think the idea was in my mind I
thought everybody else was having a
picnic but I grew up in a big city and I
that just my parents weren't doing it so
I just thought joy it'd be great to go
on a picnic that would be America
the other thing is though so when I got
married I got married on July 1st and so
on July 4th we didn't go on a honeymoon
but we were walking around Washington
waiting for the fireworks and I thought
it was great because the crowds come
people are happy you talk about a moment
of American unity it's nothing like
everybody celebrates before it goes away
on the fifth alright question six here
we go
this comes from Nancy Colburn if we
travel back to 1776
what would your occupation be Greg
Gutfeld
I think it would be a time travel agent
because if there were people coming back
I would have to be in charge of making
their plans yes yeah wonder what the
Commission would be on there okay
because if I mean realistic what job
would they have given a woman in 1776 at
that time probably not I'm not probably
gonna get to be a scout no I would like
to be a scout I don't know probably I
would hope that I would be able to do
some sort of writing or teaching or so
public relations I love it I would be a
lawyer I'm just gonna say that I would
just force my way into it somehow some
way to be a lawyer yeah maybe if I had
to like disguise myself I would do it
yeah little white wig things that you
put on and be cool yes all right Jesse I
have something in mind for you okay I
think that you should go and fight
against the British I think you should
be a soldier I probably would have been
on the British side though because those
were my people I would have been a
Redcoat and if I was on the British side
we probably would have won I would have
been the dance maker I was probably I
wanted to think about what I wanted to
do I wanted to be one of the midnight
riders they rode with Paul Revere to
warn that the British were coming I
think I'd be really good at just yelling
on the top of a horse cuz like waters
were I wanna be a cobbler why but you
want to touch people's shoes I don't
know just seems like it'd be fun to sit
around and just hammer on people's feet
be a cobbler Wow yeah on their feet I
think I'm gonna shoes
well feet shoes can't tell back then
leathery well if the founding fathers
are watching be a space or psycho
something don't be offended break didn't
mean